we have to talk about the Afghanistan
papers okay
there is a Washington Post report which
I will read a little bit from to get us
acclimated the Afghanistan papers are a
confidential trove of government
documents obtained by The Washington
Post revealing that senior US officials
failed to tell the truth about the war
in Afghanistan throughout the 18-year
campaign making rosy pronouncements they
knew to be false and hiding unmistakable
evidence that the war had become
unwinnable more than 2000 pages of
previously unpublished notes of
interviews with people who played a
direct role in the war from generals and
diplomats and aid workers and Afghan
officials have been published the quotes
are damning the what these Afghanistan
papers effectively are telling us is
that not only has it been a corrupt
disaster but that a lot of people
involved knew that it was a corrupt
poorly planned disaster for a very long
time and still the money flow continued
and the public pronouncements that this
was the right war remember Iraq okay
Iraq was the wrong war Afghanistan was
the right war 18 years it was a disaster
alright quote from Douglas lute Douglas
lute is a three-star Army General who
was the White House's Afghan wars are
during both the Bush and Obama
administrations in 2015 he said we were
devoid of a fundamental understanding of
Afghanistan we didn't know what we were
doing what are we trying to do here we
didn't have the foggiest notion of what
we were undertaking remember publicly we
were told Iraq went sideways maybe we
went in for the wrong reason but we're
doing the right thing in Afghanistan
Lieut also said if the American people
knew the magnitude of the dysfunction
2400 lives lost who will say that this
was in vain there has been a PR
management of the Afghanistan war to
portray it as properly run successful
reflecting an understanding of the
region which we lacked in Iraq and it
was all a farce The Washington Post goes
on to say that since 2001 more than
seven hundred and seven
five thousand US troops have deployed to
Afghanistan many repeatedly of those
2,300 died there nearly 21,000 were
wounded in action while with most
speaking on the assumption that their
remarks would not become public
US officials acknowledged this is from
the Afghanistan papers that their war
fighting strategies were fatally flawed
and that Washington wasted enormous sums
of money trying to remake Afghanistan
into a modern nation this is not just
about money it has been an incredible
quagmire when it comes to money but it
has been a foreign policy disaster as
well the Washington Post the interviews
also highlight the US government's
botched attempts to curtail runaway
corruption build a competent Afghan army
and police force remember we were told
we're doing really good work we're
building up their army and their police
force into one that works well and to
put a dent in Afghanistan's thriving
opium trade the US government has not
carried out a comprehensive accounting
of how much it has even spent on the war
in Afghanistan but the costs are
staggering listen to these numbers since
2001 the Defense Department State
Department and US Agency for
International Development have spent or
appropriated between nine hundred and
thirty four billion and nine hundred and
seventy eight billion we're talking
about almost a trillion dollars Geoffrey
Eggers who's a retired Navy SEAL and
White House staffer for Bush and Obama
again said to government interviewers we
now know that he said this because the
Afghanistan papers have gone public
quote what did we get for this one
trillion dollar effort was it worth a
trillion dollars after the killing of
Osama bin Laden I said that Osama was
probably laughing in his watery grave
considering how much we have spent on
Afghanistan the Afghanistan papers
described what the Washington Post calls
constant deception quote every data
point was altered to represent the best
picture possible this is according to
Bob Crowley an Army colonel who was a
senior counterinsurgency adviser surveys
for instance were totally unreliable but
reinforced that everything we was doing
we were doing was right and we became a
self licking ice cream cone this is a
scandal okay this doesn't diminish any
of Donald Trump scandals this says
nothing about it
impeachment this is a scandal it is the
type of scandal that does not get a lot
of attention
remember the Panama papers that got a
little attention but then these things
tend to fade these documents these
interview transcripts should be
front-page news for a very long time the
framing was Iraq didn't go so well but
Afghanistan is moral it's successful
we're doing the right thing it's not
corrupt we know where the money is going
we know everything that's going on and
now we find out from from people who
were on the ground there
we had no understanding of what was
going on we had no understanding of what
we were doing the accounting is a farce
claims were routinely made publicly that
things were going well when it's not
just that it was an exaggeration people
knew that it was an absolute and total
disaster this is the exposure of an
embarrassing multi-decade fiasco that is
just barely a blip on the radar and it's
not I know it's easy to say well damn
David if everybody stopped focusing less
on Trump then we would hear more about
this I don't buy that this is not the
type of story that tends to get a lot of
attention years ago there were claims
made we had Abu Ghraib right that was
the Iraqi prison where there was
horrible horrible wrongdoing by American
members of the military there were
supplementary documents and reports
about truly horrible things that were
taking place there and at other
facilities it may barely made a blip on
the radar there was no impeachment
scandal at the time there was no you
know we didn't have a president tweeting
twenty to a hundred times a day at the
time and it still did not get nearly the
attention that it deserved these stories
don't do well because corporate media
sets the narrative people died because
of bureaucratic issues a trillion
dollars is gone we have no clue what's
going on there and to the extent that
I'm able to I will continue talking
about this story because it is so
important and it is so so incredible
check out the documents yourselves
widely available online Washington Post
again as a very very good report and
summary about it the next video is
coming soon but before you go to that
please hit subscribe and like
running a test we believe that if
everybody does this
this will hugely boost us in YouTube's
algorithm and then everybody wins I'll
report back to you how this works make
sure before you go into that next video
hit subscribe hit like thank you so much